see ya
hello good evening and welcome to the
latest total war Warhammer campaign
walkthrough video today it's the turn of
the proud and vengeful dwarfs and just a
reminder that the game is still in
development so what you see here may be
subject to change
okay we're 29 turns into this particular
campaign and as you can see from the
overview map we've fully conquered our
starting province of the silver road and
we've returned the goblin infested dwarf
holds of death past province to their
rightful owners
ie us we've secured strong treaties with
our fellow dwarf and clans of Carrick as
all Barack far and Zophar who've helped
to successfully divide and push back the
various green skin tribes those of Barr
has recently dragged us into their war
with the vampiric fraction of schwarz -
nice ones are far down to the campaign
map now and this turn our armies are on
immediate recall to home territory
thorgrim here was making his way happily
towards Blackfyre pass in order to help
zip bar against its vampiric problems
and in charge of policing def pass is an
army led by sam neill mutter Kwas which
is obviously the best Wolf's name ever
however grim gore Ironhide has just
popped up from the dwarf an under way
with a 16 strong stack of green skin
filth mongers to threaten our home
settlements on the silver road so we've
got our armies beating a rather panicked
retreat towards him now here is the
jewel in the high king's crown mighty
karoake rock itself also known as ever
peak this glittering City with its rich
gem stone mine stands testament to dwarf
an engineering might and marks the stout
heart of our growing Kingdom we've been
focusing on its Civic development and
one result of this is a very tough
garrison consisting of grudge throws
quarrel 'as Thunderer's and a wall of
elite defenders in the shape of long
beards and hammers now with the whole of
the province under our control we can
enact Commandments over it and we're
currently empowering the guilds to aid
population growth and buff our trade
income diving into the dwarf tech tree
now you can see how we're looking to
dovetail that particular growth
improvement with this particular
technology the autonomy of the holes now
this will supercharge the kymaro we've
issued and helped us to expand our
settlements much more swiftly now the
dwarf tech tree differs to those of the
other races in that it fall
two core disciplines the way of the
Guild's brings improvements to civic
matters such as growth income diplomacy
and the reduction of vampiric and chaos
corruption the way of the clans branch
is devoted entirely to the improvement
of various wolf and battlefield units as
you can see here we're trying to balance
our research across both trees as we go
so our provincial development keeps pace
with our increasing military might
looking at the building browser for
kazakh iraq now and we can see how
certain high tier building chains can
only be constructed in higher-level
settlements so we're going to have to
upgrade carouser crack another two tiers
to build say the rune Forge or the
throne Hall of the High King we've also
implemented a neat hint system in the
building's UI to mark out any
prerequisites you'll need in order to
recruit certain units so if we want to
recruit flames spewing iron drakes or on
them with mighty troll hammer torpedos
you can see that a market indicating
that buildings in the engineer chain
will be required okay then let's end the
turn as our armies are all out of action
points for now
and as predicted grim gore has marched
on one of our settlements now we have a
single level one Lord here marshalling a
teeny-tiny garrison versus grim gore
significant force so there's not much
hope to be honest he's also level 8 and
is a fact wasn't enough he's already
unlocked his fabled ax gets Nick and
he's wearing the terrifying mask of e
enough even to put a doubt he dwarfed
the flight though it pains my beard to
say so
so mounts quick horn is now in the hands
of the green skins and a grudge has been
issued as a result so let's open up the
damask roam the great book of grudges
and see what's what now as factions mess
with you during the game these crimes
are recorded and grudges are duly issued
parts are playing as the dwarfs involve
settling these grudges it's best to keep
on top of them as it's an affront to
oven pride if vengeance is not exact it
keep your outstanding grudges low and
you'll enjoy improved public order and
diplomatic relations with other dwarf
plans
let the grudges stack up though and over
time you'll lose their respect and begin
to face increasingly negative
consequences
clearing grudges often brings a meaty
cash reward but may confer other
benefits as well this particular grow
beasts come grudge earned us for example
3 turns a vastly increased leadership
against the green skins during battles
so with a grudge to settle and territory
to reconquer let's get our armies on the
move we're gonna put em nil here into
marching stance and get him a nice boys
moving
and we're gonna do the same for thorgrim
will be looking to our hiking to give
grimoire the heave-ho and he's well
equipped for the task clad in glittering
scales and armed with the shrieking
blade he actually calls his Terra now
which also means he's also immune to it
so green gauze terrifying mask of II
won't be so terrifying to thorgrim we've
got some nice veteran C building up now
across his army and he's traveling with
a Thane hero character equipped with a
rune of stoicism which can be activated
in times of dire need to strengthen his
morale he'll also be useful when it
comes down to brass tacks with grim gore
and we're going for a pretty balanced
character build with thorgrim buffing
some of his campaign battle and personal
combat skills as we go I particularly
like ancestral grudge as it gives it
some really solid weapon strength
bonuses against green skins we've
already unlocked the quest for Thor
Grimm's axe of Grimm near now if we take
a look at our quest list we can see that
the next stage of the quest requires us
to recruit two gyrocopter or gyro bomber
units into his army now a lot of love
and storytelling has gone into these
quests and we're really hoping you'll
enjoy the narrative accompaniment as
well as the poacher broads okay we'll
leave thorgrim there for now I do hope
you've enjoyed this slice of dwarf
campaign gameplay and do stay tuned for
more walkthrough videos coming very soon
you